when you think about the word  Scientology what does it mean I'd rather  be dead than to be the seriously you say  that oh absolutely I contemplated just  driving into a wall and just killing her  you're being serious  absolutely suicide death would be a  better existence than living there when  you see beating people wouldn't wouldn't  punching with your fists into the face  we'd be in meanings and he would punch  people in the mood like while they're  sitting can you say and this is so hard  to believe though how can an  organization do that period under the  guise of religion you have thousands and  thousands of these little aliens  attached to you I have aliens attached  to everybody does especially you I do  get some brilliance or the people who  represented the government that approved  it to be a religion are idiots  you  [Music]  you